愚者成功。
啥类型？
我先说一下要素，首先是一个渔者。
然后。
一份伟业。
然后是一个变化。
就是一个不怎么聪明的人，能力有欠缺的人。
面对一个他适应不了的环境。
吸引不了的环境。
最后。
发生了变化。
伪装的变化，而且是。
就是他假装适应了。
怎么去理解呢？我们先来举几个例子吧，阿甘。
他认为阿甘属于这种类型的片子。
或者更我觉得更典型的其实是那个片子，绿正俏佳人。
律正俏佳人就是一个一个法廊妹，就拧拧拧拧扎扎的一个法廊妹去读一个哈佛呀，还是啥的那个一个法学院特别牛逼的一个法学院。然后呢，他在里面就显得格格不入。
格格不入，他就像一个愚者，面对一个啊啊了不得的一个。
环境或者事情搞不定，然后最后发生的变化就是。
他。
适应了这个环境，取得了成功。
但是这个变化呢又是一个伪装的变化，就是他其实还是他自己。
他其实还是他自己，他等于先探索用别人的方式解决问题，最后还是回归自己。
所以其实这种就叫娱热成功。
为什么说就是呃救猫咪的这好分类，有时候会被人攻击或者是被人挑毛病呢？就是这个愚者成功啊。
跟那个小人物那个。
小肉遇大事了。
跟小人物遇大事啊。
是有点类似的。
就是你看啊小人物嘛？一个渔者摊上大事了，去了一个法学院。
其实是有点类似的，他只不过是没有生死考验而已。
对吧。
是有点类似的，就是。
一个小人物摊上一个大事儿。
摊上一个大事儿了。
他有时候还跟如愿以偿，也有点像。
对吧就是说你看你有个愿望嘎嘣一下实现了。
你能你能弄了了吗？
但是他只不过是没有咒语。
没有教训，因为这个是负面的，就是如愿以偿。这个是负面的。你最后是现在更好，你这个是正面的，就是这个哈佛大学法学院它本身是没毛病。
挺好的。
懂这意思吧？是你最后还是需要去适应这个商学院的，只不过你不需要完全改变自己的你你的优点你需要保留。
等于它有细微的区别。
但是啊我为什么。
我说我们有时候咱们自己的那种分类方式也挺好，你全部视为小人物出大事儿。
你全部按我的思路视为小零数出大事也可以，也不会出问题。
好被制度化。
就更加玄妙了啊，跟这些啊。
被制度化跟这个又很接近很接近的。被制度化是什么？我们来先说一下它的要素。首先。
要有一个群体。
因为你被制度了嘛。
就说一个个体被一种制度给束缚了。
首先你要有一个群体。
你是个啥样的群体？
对吧。
为什么能束缚住个人呢？
就首先你得有一个群体。
然后呢。
要有一个选择，主角有一个选择。
在个人。
和这个群体之间，他要做出一个选择。然后最后呢。
他要做出抗争和牺牲。
抗争的牺牲。
怎么去理解啊？我还是举例子吧。
飞跃风人怨。
崔悦峰人员。
教父。
飞越风人院是一个正常人。
被关在了风瑞院里。
这个群体就是一群疯子，一疯人员。
然后他要做出一种选择。
就是我是跟他们一块装疯呢。
还是要保持我的认知和理性。
然后做出抗争，做出牺牲，就他要冲出去，他要跑出去。
当然了，他没成功。
被人。
弄成白痴了。
教父。
一个群体。
就是他的家族整个这个。
西西利这黑手党的这个家族庞大的家族，严密的家族制度传统习惯。
行为模式。
这个群体。
被呃教父的主角是那个那个。
呃，迈克柯里昂嘛对吧？迈克是主角，用他的视角来讲的话。
他面对的群体就是这个家族。
那他的个人选择就是我我是离开这个家族。
去。
做一个正常人。
做一个平民，对吧？还是回到这个家族。
就成为黑社会。
迈克上来就有这个选择吧。
而且这个选择当时开始的时候是一半一半的很宽容的。
就他家里人是希望他呃别碰生意，别碰这些杀人的东西，大哥二哥来碰就可以了，对吧？你不要碰这些东西，就上来这个选择是完全给到你的。
但是出事情是出在他父亲受重伤。
父亲被人暗杀。
所以他最做出了牺牲，就我去。
女朋友也掰了吗？
他最心爱的女人也掰了吗？
等于他做出的牺牲都是很外化的。
做出了牺牲。
决定。
投身家族。
服务群体。所以你看啊被制度化啊。
也跟那些很接近是吧？它不像前5个，前5个真的很容易理解。
后5个我为什么写在这边？那那个斯戴德先生不是按照这个顺序讲的。
我为什么把这些放在这儿？因为这些确实费解，它有细微的区别。但是你我们今天既然要讲究猫咪，就从它的角度去理解这10个故事。
1个故事类型，它不一定是电影类型。我说过啊，我说过一个片子有可能跨两个类型。
他有可能是两个类型之间，有可能是两个类型都有。
有可能是两个类型并列，也有可能是两个类型前后都有可能。
这是1种讲故事的。
出发点，它每一种最起码给你打的几个点。
我们说打这个点是很重要的。
打这个点是很重要的。
不要觉得斯耐德先生打这几个点，你觉得啊哎他不就每一种说了三个要求嘛？简单的嘞，绝对不是这样的绝对不是这样的。我们说爱情片来。
我说这几年爱情片越来越少了吧。
但是去年年底有一部的又要说了，我们单位那个办个喜剧。
那个爱情片。
他就是个爱情片，它叫半个喜剧，另外半个就是爱情。
他就是爱情片。
他从节构上。
这几年爱情片越来越少，就是因为爱情片不好做，他非要做非要做，他就是没做好。
我们说没说好，就是因为他这个要素都做做的不做的不行。
要素做的不行。
然后就导致不行来爱情边的要素是什么？
我们说他说的是就他说的是主角零件和勾，我说就两个，就是这两个人彼此需要。
彼此离不开，彼此需要。但是。
有个沟。
半个喜剧里面男女主角彼此需要吗？
不太需要。
你没做出来。
没有做出来，他们俩是。
必须在一块儿。
没有做出来，他们俩是天造地设的一双，没有做出来。
上来。
就是那种。
欢喜冤家只做出了一点欢喜冤家的感觉。
就说首先你这个。
两个人之间的这个。
引力就没做出来。
我们说一般爱情应该做什么样的引力，这个男的。
没有人一个人瞧得起她，然后这个女的送来了温暖。
哎，让观众马然觉得天哪，这是天使啊。
对吧没有一个人屌他呀。
或者这个男的不敢跟任何女孩说话，一辈子没有跟任何一个女的说过话，因为特别的腼腆。但是看到这个女孩的时候，竟然痴痴的望着人家，一上来就给观众一种我天哪，别别不行了，别错过，错过这个再没了，对吧？你以为你必须给营造给观众一种他俩，必须在一块的那种。
那种感觉。
或者是从行为上一个残缺，一个是零件，就是要特别明确。
但是你这个半个喜剧杀来这个男女主角。
没有在一起的。
必要的证据。
你让观众就很难。
其他俩特别揪心，然后你这个没有，然后你勾也没做好。
就你男女主角之间要有一个沟壑吧。
我之前说过啊，我说沟壑啊。
为什么这几年爱情销越来越少？是因为沟壑不好做，前面这个能做到了。
一男一女必须在一块其实能做到的，有很多方法的有很多方法的。
对吧？
比如说这两个人莫名的来电，就是那种一天见面10次。
有很多作种片子啊，就你不停的跟这个人偶遇。
你就是在强烈的暗示观众，他俩必须在一块，必须在一块，天造地设，妻视怨旅，上辈子也在一块儿。
明白这个意思吗？就是说让观众认为这一男一女必须在一块儿是有办法的。
但是这个勾啊是特别不好做了特别不好做了。一般做钩都是做生死。
生死钩啊。
就这个沟壑得是生死的程度，才能让观众真的。
着急。
真的。
哎呀，难受说哎呀，不行不行不行。
呃呦，我我。
这个这个勾太大了。
我给你举个例子嘛，就是说如果一男一女要在一块儿，假设这个爱情片啊，你跟观众说这一男一女。
相爱哎呀，在一块就好了。然后观众认可了。观众说，哎呀，我就是想让他俩在一块儿，然后你跟观众讨价还价说，但是如果他俩在一块儿。
得死一个。
然后观众马上就揪心了，觉得啊哦我天哪，为什么爱情多魔，对吧？观众就会揪心。
这就是沟壑得到这个程度。
我给你量化一下啊，你如果跟观众说哎，他俩在一块儿。
这男的得瞎一只眼，女的得瘸一条腿。
观众麻雅说，那在一起呀，爱情最大了，一只眼睛算什么？
观众一定这么说，为什么？
因为观众看惯了生死沟壑了，他会觉得。
缺条腿怕什么？另外一条腿拄着拐走了。
实际在现实生活中，你说你要跟一个人在一块，你必须瞎一只眼，他必须瘸条腿。你们俩他妈的绝对不会你们俩双方握一下手，再见，对吧？不啰嗦，没有必要，干嘛呀，对不对？瞎一只眼瘸条腿，但是在戏里瞎一只眼瘸条腿这个。
沟壑太小了，观众不买账，观众希望是大沟深沟深不见底得死人。
那你说。
这个呃呃。
半个喜剧里面的勾是啥？
是这个男的，如果跟这个女女主在一块，他有可能会得罪他的朋友，得罪他的朋友会有一个什么后果呢？北京户口就拿不着了。
就说一段伟大的爱情败给了北京户口，明白这个意思吗？
在现实生活中可以的在现实生活中啊。
一个户北京户口好几十万呢，就如果要买的话。
那你说你为了一个好几十万，你有可能会掂量一下，哎，算了，反正也刚认识，对吧？再找找吧，再找个别的嘛，没有必要的一棵树上吊死。但是在戏里观众不买账。
观众会觉得我的天哪，就你这儿还叭叭给我讲真爱呢。然后因为一个北京户口在这犹豫，在这缩，还叭叭给我讲一个两个小时的故事，我才不看呢。就这个问题你这个勾啊浅互相之间又没有必要的在一块，然后沟又很浅，你这个偏台看什么？
明白吗？所以说这爱评生还是特别难弄。
我说爱情片的勾啊。
我之前课上给大家讲过爱情片的沟啊，我见过最大的沟啊。
我见过爱情片里面最大的沟是啥沟呢？
就男女主角要在一块儿之间，两个人之间有条沟，最大一条沟是琼瑶阿姨挖的。
求瑶阿姨挖的那条沟叫梅花烙。
我们说一般男女之间男女之间的沟是生死，罗密欧与朱丽叶两家有仇，对吧？两家是生死仇，你们俩在一块儿，那得死人，最后他俩确实对吧？也也也也那啥了，也死了。然后呢，梁山伯与祝英台。
对吧那不能在一块，在一块儿得死人，然后俩都死，这沟就够深的了。
都没有穷瑶阿姨挖的狠。梅花落什么剧情回忆一下。
没话唠说。
这个男主角和女主角相爱。
男主角是什么人呢？男主角是贝勒也。
贝勒也，女主角是民间女子。
但其实是什么呢？
是当年男主角的妈。
是个妃子吗？
生了一个女孩，一看，我操女孩，但是她要争宠。
在皇帝那儿争宠上位，然后呢就用让他身边的丫鬟换了一个男孩。
报告给皇上说，我给你生了个太子。
自己不就母凭子贵吗？就上位。但是这个女孩呢一这是自己身上掉下来的肉呀，又舍不得她又觉得我以后。
我的。
一有朝一日，对吧？我把那老头熬死，我得把我闺女可能得找回来什么的，对吧？
然后就拿起梅一个梅花簪子。
在火上一烤，在这个小婴儿的肩膀上烙了一个梅花状的疤，梅花形状的疤。
落在这个小女孩，然后肩膀上，然后把小女孩送出宫，送到民间去抚养了。
自此之后杳无异信，然后他就带着这个小男孩母平子贵，然后就升为什么，对吧？然后这小子就是贝这是贝勒爷呀，这呃不不叫贝勒爷，叫太子啊，对吧？叫太子呃呃，是皇上的对，皇子是太子。
然后就就叼起来了。
好死不死呢，太子到民间去打猎，他们清朝那个那个太子不都喜欢打猎嘛？打猎之后与这个民间一个女孩相识，相恋，相知相爱。
坠入爱河，开始的时候呢也没啥，觉得那十八九的大小伙子看上一个小妞。
谈个恋爱很正常，他妈也觉得没啥，后来结果一不小心。
一不小心。
这个这个看到这个女孩的肩膀完了。
梅花烙。
这是自己的亲女儿，明白这个意思吧？亲女儿和自己掉包的这个假太子。
谈恋爱。
能让他们俩人在一块儿吗？
能让他们俩在一块儿吗？
他们俩要是在一块，这件事情穿帮了以后。
这不是死一个人啊。
是死全家呀，双方死全家这个女孩，这个女孩的爸妈这个男孩，这个太子这个这个太子他妈和当年经手的这些所有丫鬟婆子全部得死。就这件事情严重到这种程度。
所以我这我说这个梅花道这个戏啊。
好看不好看，另说。但是琼瑶阿姨挖的这条沟。
是爱情片历史上最深的沟。
现象级大深沟。
就是爱我爱我请死全家，爱我，咱俩死全家。
就到这种程度。
所以说这是爱情片。
然后这10种类型是10种故事。
他每一种。
的这个元素。
都是有用的。我就想跟大家说这个，你要理解这种元素对我们写故事是有帮助的。
你看一下打眼，看一下你的故事，大概属于哪种类型。然后你去看一看它这几种元素，你有没有完成任务。
说说很简单，有些人就是做不到。前些年我还看过一个鬼屋片啊。
鬼屋片。
那个片名我不记得了，是个烂片，苏有朋演的。
几年前，苏有朋演的一个。
就是恐怖片在一个山顶的别墅里。
连环法死人啊，反正反正呃恐怖片那个片子啊，我们说鬼屋片就三个元素。
他当然有十虚列吧元素那些，但是有三样东西是人家鬼屋片里面列出来的，你必须要做好的，一是一个空间，啥叫空间？密闭空间锁定空间，你跑不掉的空间，这叫空间。二是有一股神秘力量，要你命。
要你命啊。
3。
是有原罪。
是有原罪。我们说中国的恐怖片啊很少很少了，拍不太好。为什么一般是蛇在这儿，一般是蛇在这儿，折在力量上。
因为我们不允许有。
超自然的力量。
所以你看中国的恐怖片最后全部解释为精神分裂或者是一场梦。
或者是。
某个女疯子的想象。
对吧或者是就是一场误会。
这就没有劲儿，你知道吗？这个力量首先这个超自然的力量，它就没有力量。就这么说吧，你就三缺一了，你就瘸腿的。
所以中国的恐怖片一般都不好看。
但是恐怖片呢其实是高需，市场上还是需要的。所以你三缺一就三缺一了。另外两条腿支棱着。
也走呗，也给大家看一看吧。但是那个我看过那个苏有朋的那个主演的那个那那个电影，为什么那么烂，那么不好看呢？就这个首先肯定是折了，对吧？然后呢，他把这个也给折了。
把空间也给折了。
为啥呢？
就是我看这个片子了，他们不是在一个别墅里面，然后别墅里面发生非常恐怖的事件，不停的死人嘛。
不停的死人。
我从头到尾就想问一个事儿，就是你们都吓成这样了，为什么没有一个人想一想开门走呢？
你能不能就走？
你回家去行不行？
是没有二路汽车了，还是。
还是还是谁给你栓在这儿了？
对吧。
你电锯惊魂那是直接拴在那儿了，懂我意思吧？侏罗纪公园那是整个岛。
都是恐龙，你没有地方逃，无处可逃，这才叫空间，这才叫锁住你密闭你你才能让你害怕呀。
对吧你不能说这儿有个鬼屋，哇，天哪，太吓人了。哎呀，我哥们儿死了，哎呦，我兄弟也死了，哎呦，我喜欢的女孩也死了。我天哪，我怎么吓死那你回家呀。
就出去啊。
咦，奇怪吧。
鬼屋这么强，人你出去啊。
对不对？你干嘛在这里？
所以那种片子就很烂。
就是这个问题，他就连这最基本的他都做不到。
直好几条腿啊就没法看了这种片子。
所以说是这十0个类型好吧，我们这节课呢就是讲这些十个类型一定要。
理解。
他每一种类型。
人家那个着力点是什么意思？
其实是有用的。
其实也是真的有区别的。
但是呢也不用去迷信。
给大家提供一种新的思路。
行，我先说到这儿。